in the time it takes this cat to make a
leap of faith name four types of
takeaway Chinese Indian Pizza I were on
deck and we're about to play animal
timers for Tyler any time it takes this
dump to escape name five news outlets go
what times yes easy stuff just getting
you in there just warmin looks good I
feel good okay right
in the time it takes this dog to ascend
to the ceiling French onion as I got to
minestrone in the time it takes this dog
to climb one step in full let's go
George Sampson diversity attraction I
think the dog was up on the stair the
top was under step you could have got
Ashley input Z oh I could have had
Lourdes the speed 12 see your each eye
MacDowell your head goes in the time it
takes this cat to make a leap of faith
name four types of takeaway Chinese
Indian pizza hey I love a grid halloumi
hello falafel Melanie tabbouleh salad
it's all aboveboard
in the time it takes for this dog to
make a splash name five famous British
people gold the Queen Prince William
Prince Harry
don't smushed no points monarchy you
went for Jeremy zero
Jeremy Clarkson Jeremy Corbyn Jeremy
cool how's it goin did you know I said
you had one that would have been a good
one ha ha
in the time it takes this cut to shake
off the teeth man 5 livers tinkle green
tea
all great calamine healing do you wash
down your liberties yes ok ok check this
one out
ah huh in the time it takes this bearded
dragon Lauretta
to pick up the worm limb for sources
sauce mayonnaise it's a good barbecue
for this guy he's gone shooting in the
time it takes this dog to pop this
balloon name five TV personalities up
McCallum Declan Donnelly Stephen Mulhern
draaby Walsh and Jeremy Kyle it was very
ITV Heavy D do I have to worry about
this thing you got Bradley wash at the
mines it's actually not Bradley it's it
just happens to be there in the time it
takes this cut to give up just to give
up yeah name five woods that run back to
have you tried again with blow hello
gets no blow snow plow plow bull oh yeah
and the time takes for this dog to
abandon its stick to me in five things
you find that a roast in a go roast
potato is guilty pudding meat carrots
cabbage oh please yeah you did it you do
did I see how to close my eyes for that
and dance Rusty's Yorkshire
Hot Lips the time it takes this pug to
wake up named fall you can't
supermarkets go
Morrison's test score as does Sandra's
oh that was bad even good yes good in
the time it takes this dog to brick
spaghetti twice twice named for famous
comedians go Michael McIntyre dance
Jason Manford Kevin Keith Bishop John
Bishop thank you very much everybody
thank you sweet sweet victory
we have been Ant & Dec and that is just
one Alamo time as for Tyler very much
thank you